you don't really stress a lot do you  think now that you have a lead role in  this other series and it's very  demanding and you're abigail walker is  that do you feel any of the load do you  feel the stress i i'm not feeling all  right i would i would say i always think  of it as a responsibility at more than a  stressor or a pressure because you know  obviously there is a lot writing you  know for a lack of a better horsepower  yeah yeah on this show and on this  character and and there's a lot of  expectation for it but  those are the sort of jobs that i love  because it is a challenge and it is  something that it forces me to rise to  the occasion not that i wouldn't attempt  to anyway